Watch me.
form has been bin.
>> Yes, sir.
Happy Memorial Day, I think.
>> Thank you. Happy Memorial Day to you.
Thank you for your service.
>> Well, no, but at any rate, how are you?
>> I'm good. Thank you.
>> Let's uh day went by really fast as all
days do.
>> I I hear you. How How was
>> Yeah, we were we were in Florida a month
ago. Over a month ago. Six weeks ago.
>> It was a while ago. H how how was your
trip? Your your secondary trip that you
took to my city? It was good. It was in
and out. Oh, it it's a tough city, man.
Holy cow. And I was staying in Time
Square. Oh my god.
>> You know what? And you know where you
were staying and when you when you said
where you were going to be staying, I
was going to kind of be like, really?
>> You know why I stay there is because
it's walking distance from the show,
>> you know, so I could walk. You could
>> But I'm never I'm never doing that. I'm
never doing that again. Ever.
>> You could do 34 Street right there.
It probably been cheaper, too.
>> No, I'm gonna I'll stay up town or
something and then take a cab. It was
terrible.
>> It was terrible. In fact, you know, I
don't even like I shouldn't say
anything, but it's it's a tough city.
It's a really tough city. You know, it
is.
>> Yes, sir. Yes, sir.
>> Well, I'm glad you back in one piece. We
need you here.
>> Thank you.
>> And um we're just uh trying to get
folks. We got uh Bruce there and and you
know
>> I met Victor. I saw Victor.
>> You met Victor.
>> Yeah,
>> Victor's Victor is a good man.
>> Good man. Yes, he is.
>> Did you Did you help him with his
friends concerns? And
>> uh I'm pretty sure I I tried to pretty
sure I did.
>> You know, you know Victor,
you know Sky School?
>> Um I've heard of it. Good school. I know
that. Yeah, Victor went there. You got
>> He's a smart guy.
>> Is he on the call?
>> Uh, I'm sure he'll be in the I'm sure
he'll be in the chat. Thank you, Bruce.
>> Good. Good. Bruce is always with us. Um,
you know, interesting topic uh that you
um sent to me last week. We didn't get a
chance to talk about it, but
>> remind me remind me what the headline
was. Do you have it? Can you post it?
So, we have um I I I I put as our title.
I'm gonna put it in our little chat
here.
>> Uh let's help folks with Parkinson's.
>> Okay. Parkinson's is so it's so easy and
I've been working with Parkinson's
patients for a long time. It's such an
easy health challenge to deal with
because um it's really caused by the
same thing that causes everything else.
But what people are when people have
Parkinson's disease, they're
experiencing the end result of longterm.
It's always long term. It doesn't happen
quickly unless somebody gets poisoned.
Sometimes it can happen quickly or brain
damaged like like Muhammad Ali, you
know, they when you get punched in the
head a lot. Um, but almost always it's
the result of the same thing that causes
everything. It's so crazy to me. I I
feel guilty even, you know, trying to
position myself as an adviser when it's
just so simple. So real quickly, all
chronic disease is inflammatory. There's
no such thing as a chronic degenerative
condition that's not inflammatory.
Right?
>> That's premise number one. Right? So we
work here logically. Premise number one
is all chronic degenerative diseases are
inflammatory. Premise number two is
inflammation is a protective response or
defensive response. Premise number three
is if you have a protective response or
a defensive response, you have an
offending agent.
And premise number four is if you want
to end the defensive response, you got
to eliminate the offending agent,
>> right?
>> It's just that simple. And you know, I
don't know why there's It doesn't It's
not complicated, is it? It's not hard to
understand. Offending agent, defensive
response, inflammation, disease.
That's it.
>> We overthink it. We overink it. It's
just simple. Put the good stuff in and
the bad. keep the bad stuff out and put
the good stuff in.
>> Okay. But you know, um, when folks when
folks are diagnosed with this problem,
they're going to get their leodopa.
They're going to get their carbodopa.
>> What does levodopa and carbodopa do?
>> Okay. It it it um
it feeds the brain.
>> No, it's hormone replacement. It's
hormone replacement.
>> Is it really?
>> Yeah. Except it's not exactly. It's
neuro hormones. help. Most when most
people think of hormone replacements,
they're talking about steroid hormones.
These are nerve or brain hormones, neuro
hormones.
>> Okay? Dopamine is the neuro hormone.
Leodopa and carbodopa are precursors and
they get turned into dopamine.
>> Nobody's solving the problem. They're
just replacing the hormones that are not
present. It's like thyroid hormone. If
you have a high, if you have a thyroid,
the gland, you have a a degenerating
gland or an inflamed gland or somehow a
defective gland or it's being attacked
by the immune system. If you have
Hashimoto's,
you have a gland problem. So, what is
the remedy? They can't do anything about
the gland.
>> So, what do they do? They give you more
hormone.
You are you following me? So, the
strategy is not to solve the problem.
It's to reduce the symptom.
The problem with and the issue with
leodopa and carbon do is they don't work
very often or they they work over time
they work less and less because they
they're haven't they haven't stopped the
degeneration.
It's the degeneration
that is the problem.
It's it's like
how can I what's a good example? If you
have a tree, go back to a tree, right?
And it's not giving fruit and you're a
farmer and you need your tree to give
apples. You have an apple tree. You
could stick apples on the tree. You
could go to the grocery store, buy a
bunch of apples, stick them on the tree,
and then you'll have an apple tree,
right? But eventually the apple, you're
not going to have any more apples and
you're still going to have a rotten
tree. We want to fix the tree.
That's what we're about here is fixing
the tree. We say the root, not the
fruit, but what we're really talking
about is fixing the the the organ
organism, the tree or the brain or or
the um or the thyroid, whatever part of
the body it is. That's what we want to
fix. Doctrine doesn't do it. And they're
not bad people. They're not dumb people.
They're not malicious people. Sometimes
they're a little arrogant, a little
chauvinistic. That's true. But the
practice of medicine is very helpful in
the sense that if you have an injury,
you know, you want to have it repaired
and in the sense that if you have
miserable symptoms like you're shaking
and Parkinson's, you want to do
something something symptomatically. But
to solve the problem, you've got to go
to the degenerative organ or tissue.
In the case of in the case of the um in
case of Parkinson's, it's a part of the
brain that's called the substantionigra.
I don't want to get into too much of the
details here. It doesn't matter.
Although it's interesting the substantia
[__] that means the black substance,
right? It's melanin. It's pigment. And
melanin is an absolutely fascinating
molecule. It's no accident that people
have a lot of melanin age slower. Black
people notoriously are, you know, some
you ever see black women who are like 80
years old and they don't have any
wrinkles.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. It's melanin, you know. So melanin
is amazing stuff. It's in the brain
because it conducts electricity. So when
that area of the part of the brain when
that area of the brain deteriorates, you
don't make melanin. I'm sorry. You don't
make dopamine. And the doctor's strategy
is to give dopamine or at least a
precursor of dopamine. I'm saying let's
slow down the progress of the
degeneration. And the reason I say it's
easy is because it is. And I've been
saying this for years. Work on your
foods. Work on your intestine. Everybody
with Parkinson's disease will know that
they've had digest. everybody
they had digestive problems for a long
time now. I shouldn't say everybody
because sometimes people don't recognize
it. Sometimes people don't remember it
or they don't notice it. And I think I
told a story. Did I tell it on I forgot
if I told it on this show or not. I was
talking to a gal, a young lady. She had
really bad skin. Did I tell that story?
>> Well, I remember. Yeah.
>> And she didn't she said she said, "Ah, I
didn't notice any I didn't notice a
relationship between foods and and uh my
symptoms." I was like, "Really? that
didn't make any sense to me because you
always notice and so I said why don't
you show me the food diary so she took a
picture of the food diary she shows me
the food diary and on the lefth hand
side in blue it has all these foods
terrible foods beans and rice and and u
burritos and and uh you know just a
whole list of foods that you wouldn't
want to eat cereals and that kind of
thing spam and then on the right hand
side in red ink it said bloated crampy
diarrhea just had a whole list of things
and I said, "Her name is Chloe." I think
it was Chloe. He said, "Chloe, well, it
says it right in your food diary. It
says the foods and the problems." She
didn't make the connection.
She didn't realize they were connected.
And it was right in front of her in her
own handwriting. And that's the kind of
disconnect we all have. We got to get
past it. It's not because she's stupid.
She just didn't make that connection.
She told me, "No, there's no rel no
relationship." And I was like, "What?
It's right there." Mrs.
B. I think I well Becca Becca mentions
that she's had three people in the last
four weeks with Parkinson's symptoms and
you know I've faced
>> go online right now like you did last
week look up Parkinson's and dispiosis
right now Parkinson's and dispiosis
or Parkinson's and intestinal
permeability
or Parkinson's and endotoxins or
Parkinson's and lipopolyaccharides
uh gut permeability,
>> gut permeabil permeability and
microbiota in Parkinson's disease.
>> It's all over the place. It's all over
the place. I'm not making this up. I
mean, I I happen to have seen it because
it's just it's logical, but if you want
to go online, look it up. Look it up.
This is not odd. It's not strange. It's
not oddball.
But pharmacist Ben, but but I guess you
know what I'm what I'm dealing with as
as a struggle. And by the way, um before
I get into that, you you mentioned um
melatonin.
>> Yes.
>> Melanin melanin.
>> Melanin.
>> What's the difference between melatonin
and melanin real quick?
>> Melanin is a pigment. Melatonin is a
hormone.
Melanin is a color. It's black.
>> Melanie's black. Melanin is a black. You
got lots of melanin in your skin.
There's melanin.
>> I really
>> lots of melanin. You're rich in melanin.
>> No, you're Mr. Melanin. Melanin. They
make They make computer chips out of
melanin.
>> Melanin is an incredible molecule.
>> I did a There's a I have a I have a I
did an interview with George Nory and
it's on Tik Tok now and it's got like I
don't know four million views or some
crazy amount of views with me talking
for 30 or 60 seconds on melanin
>> and and people reposted it all over the
place. I think Tik Tok.
>> Okay. But then melatonin is not a
derivative.
>> Melaton no nothing at all. Melatonin is
a hormone that's a very important
hormone. Melatonin is involved in sleep
and also in um uh digestive health.
>> Melatonin is a fabulous fabulously
valuable hormone. Very protective
antioxidant. It's amazing molecule.
Melanin is a pigment.
>> Okay?
>> There's no mel you can't take melanin
orally.
>> It's a pigment. But you can take
melatonin orally.
>> Okay. But in the article, it mentioned
sleep being a factor for Parkinson's.
>> When we sleep, when we sleep, our brain
cleans itself out. You have a part of
your brain called the it's like a like a
a circulatory system for waste. It's
called the glimpmphatic system. The
brain and neurons, nerve cell, brain
cells are constantly making waste
because they're constantly working. When
a cell constantly works, it makes waste.
That waste has to be drained out under
conditions of nutritional deficiencies
and exytotoxins and poor living and
smoking and drinking and drugs. The
waste accumulates. So over time, if the
lymphatic system is not draining out,
that waste will cause toxicity. So sleep
is one of the ways we detox our brain.
And that's true, but dementia also. And
by the way, Parkinson's
can cause some Parkinson's disease,
which is a movement disorder, is
associated with something called
Parkinson's dementia. It's one of the
types of dementia. And who cares if you
forget where you lost your keys or
you're delusional.
You don't care if it's Alzheimer's
dementia or Parkinson's dementia,
Louisbody dementia. That's irrelevant
distinction. That's a red herrings.
Doesn't matter. It matters that the part
of your brain is deteriorating and it's
and it's making you uh demented. It
doesn't matter whether it's the Louis
bodies that are there or whether it's in
the area near the substantia [__] for
for for Parkinson's or it's the
prefrontal cortex for Alzheimer's. That
doesn't matter. They create irrelevant
distinctions
and we fall for it. So, oh I I I don't
have Alzheimer's. I have Louisbody
dementia. Oh, I I don't have Louis body
dementia. I have Parkinson's dementia.
It doesn't matter. It's a degenerative
condition of the brain of the organ
called the brain. No matter what it is,
the word the proper word is
degeneration,
not Parkinson's. Do you get it? We don't
want we want to get away from the
nomenclature and we want to return back
to these generic biochemical breakdowns.
You can't treat Parkinson's, but you can
treat degeneration.
Follow me?
>> Yes. You can't treat the nomenclature,
but you can treat the biochemistry.
That's why when they say, "Oh, you're
not allowed to say Parkinson's, and
you're not allowed to say diabetes, and
you know, we're not allowed to say that.
Only your doctor can say diabetes, but
we can say dislycemia.
You're not allowed to say Crohn's
disease, but I can say intestinal
disease." You know what I'm saying? We
want to get back to the biochemistry
because that will elucidate the
mechanism and the mechanism is what you
treat. You treat the mechanism. You
don't treat the nomenclature.
If you're stuck in the nomenclature,
you're going to be what the heck do I
do? I have retinitis pigmentotosa. I
have hydrogenitis superativa. I have
transerythrid. What was that crazy one?
We heard transariththrin amalloidosis.
>> Wow. Whatever. You know, it's
>> point word.
It's inflammation, degeneration,
breakdown. It's all inflammatory. And
that simplifies everything. And our
mission here, our mission here is to
take this whole health question away
from authorities and bring it back to
our homes. If it's in a if it's in an
authority's hands, you're out of
control. Now I got to go to the doctor.
Now I got to go to the hospital. Now I
got to have tests done. Now I got to go
to the pharmacy. Now I got to take
different drugs that I don't know what
they're doing to my body. Now I got to
have this organ removed or that organ
removed or have some kind of surgical
procedure. If you put it back into your
into your home, now you can control with
lifestyle, with your foods, with your
exercise, with your sleep, with your
hydration, with your stress levels, with
your supplementation. You see what I'm
saying? This is our goal. Our goal is to
return health back to its rightful
owner, us,
not to the authorities.
That's really the key. And and and
there's times you need authorities. You
need somebody to guide you. That's true.
But ultimately the treatments and the
remedies are not theirs. They're ours.
Only we care about our families. Only we
care about ourselves. The doctor might
care a little bit, but nobody not like
we do.
>> Okay. Yes.
>> I got a little push back.
>> So what do you do for Let me say Okay,
good. I I like push back but hang on a
second. Let me just say something. So
you know we always go down these rabbit
holes for Parkinson's. A, food diary,
eliminate problem foods. B, all your
digestive support, your nightly essence,
Dr. AR's liver cleanse, I26, daily
digest, ultimate enzymes, fucoid Z, uh,
collagen peptides, glucagel caps,
anything. Vitamin A and vitamin E, both
of which are important for the
intestinal lining. Um, cleaning the
blood with chelating agents, an
acetylcyine and vitamin C. Focus on the
gut and focus on the blood which is
secondary to the gut. That's how you
treat Parkinson's. And if you want
proof, fast. And when you fast, you'll
notice that you don't have the same
symptoms. You got to eat obviously, but
fast for a day or two. And if you want a
quick emergency fix, take a bath because
when the you've activated the
parasympathetic nervous system and your
muscles are relaxed, you're not going to
be as shaky. Okay. Now, what were you
going to push back on? Well, um, you
make it sound very easy, but we deal
with folks who,
you know, because they're still using
the medication and other medications and
um, and I'm going to lead into Becca's
question, but uh, they they use
medications, they use uh, specifically
the carbodopa, leodopa, they use other
medications for other symptoms that they
have bodily. I mean clearly you know
they you know a lot of these folks are
dealing with metabolic syndrome uh
they're dealing with the gut uh
dispiosis and what I'm suggesting is
that the time frame in which these folks
are healing or not healing is uh lengthy
and it it it
>> the time frame that sitting in the time
frame is what time frame is lengthy
>> they're they're they're dealing with
these symptoms for a long time. They're
dealing with these problems for a long
time
>> because they haven't come to us yet.
They're going to the doctor.
>> Even the ones that have come to us and,
you know, maybe use part of the
chocolate, you know, chocolate cake
recipe. I give them a full recipe for
the chocolate cake. They use part of the
recipe and they're not getting where
they want to be. They're they're still
relying on the carbodopa and the
leodopa.
>> Look, I can't help pe people to do
whatever they want to do. I'm not I
can't go into their homes and and force,
you know, force them not to eat or force
them to eat different foods.
>> I'm just telling you how you handle it.
I'm just telling you how you handle it.
>> What about metabolic syn metabolic
syndrome is an issue too because
metabolic syndrome will inflame the
liver. Once once the liver is inflamed,
then you get more blood toxicity.
metabolic syndrome will um cause
gallbladder problems that will cause
malabsorption of fats and then you'll
have problems with um with absorption of
vit your fatty vitamins your omega fats
that will affect your brain. So yeah,
these are all involved but it starts
with dirty blood which which itself
starts with uh leaky gut and dispiosis.
So you do you do what you can do. Number
one, you f what's it? Look, it's the
same thing. The triangle. You focus on
the gut first. You focus on the blood
sugar second, blood sugar system second.
And then you calm the body down. That's
point three. Calm everything down.
Relax. Muscle relaxation, massage,
breathing, slow, deep rhythmic
breathing. Making sure you're getting
enough rest. Hot tubs or hot baths or
warm showers. everything you do to relax
the body. So, I mean, right now, AJ,
close your eyes. Close your eyes right
now and think about put place your
attention on the bottom of your feet
that are touching the floor. Feel them
touching the floor. Feel your feet
touching the floor. The pressure of your
feet touching the floor. And now work
yourself up to your uh calf muscles. And
as you're working yourself up to the
calf muscles, soften your calf muscles.
And as you're working up your calf
muscles, go to your thighs. Making sure
you're breathing. Make sure you're
watching. Not not changing your
breathing. Just watching how your body
automatically breathes. Your body
breathes totally by itself. You don't
have to do a thing. It's like a rhythm
on its own. You go back to your thighs
and feel how your thighs are softening
up. Play a lot of attention. Place all
your attention in your thighs. And then
move out up your thighs and feel your
butt sitting on the seat. Feel the
pressure of the seat. Feel the pressure
of your butt sitting on the seat. Make
sure you're breathing. Not changing your
breath. Just watching your breathing.
And then work to your belly. Soften the
muscles of your belly. Just stay right
like that.
And now open your eyes. And how do you
feel?
>> Feel good. Take
>> it took about took about 15 seconds.
>> 15 seconds. You lowered your blood
pressure. You reduced your inflammatory
markers. You added your healing mark.
You improved your healing markers. and
you probably added a couple minutes to
your life. As simple as that. And we
could do it. You could do that every
hour. Take 10 seconds, 15 seconds.
>> I appreciate I appreciate that very
much, Hunter. Our guy, Hunter. Um Um
Okay, Becca, come ask her question
because you had a question.
Go.
>> Yes. So, I've been off for a few weeks
and in that time I've had
>> I've missed you, too. Thank you.
>> I've had at least three people come to
me with symptoms and wanting to know
what to do with Parkinson's. So, I'm
super excited that we are talking about
this tonight.
>> Put somebody on who has Parkin Is there
somebody on the call who has
Parkinson's?
>> Um, I don't have anybody here on the
call with
>> Can they come next week? Can they come
Friday or next week?
>> I will invite them.
>> Invite them Friday or next week. We'll
talk to them on the air. We'll we'll
show them how they how easy this is.
>> So, I have two questions.
>> And if you want a quick down and dirty
I'm sorry. If you want a quick down and
dirty, tell them to take a warm bath and
that will slow down the contractions.
>> Okay. So, what can we do about um those
that are on medicines blocking the
dopamine?
>> There are no medicines that block
dopamine. There's medicines that support
do you mean for Parkinson's
>> for blocking? Well, just in general,
things like the antiscychotics or the
anti
>> antiscychot that those kinds of drugs.
So, you're saying what do you do if they
have Parkinson's and you're on an
antiscychotic?
>> Oh, they are on these prescriptions
>> and they have Parkinson's like symptoms.
>> They have movement disorders. Yes. They
call them tardive disynesia. Have you
heard of that term? Tardive disynesia.
Yeah. Tardive disynesia is a movement
disorders like ticks, that kind of thing
that people will get and you may have
seen them. You may have seen people like
that. They're psychotic. They're an
antiscychotics and one of the sides is
is like this kind of thing. Yeah. Like
that. So So guess what the guess what
the treatment is? More drugs. They give
drugs for the [__] of disanesia.
>> So you know, and that's how that's how
our system works. Look, we cannot help
people who want to work with the system.
I shouldn't say that. We can help
everybody, but we can't help people
maximally if they want to work with the
system. There's going to be like it'll
be like having a hole. It'll be like
being in a boat with a hole in it. You
you might be able to bail water and not
sink, but you're not going to go very
far. And so, if you're going to work
with the medical model, that's fine.
More power to you, but it's going to be
much harder for you to actually deal
with the deal with the problem because
now you're putting more toxicity on and
more load on the body and you haven't
solved the real problem. The good news
is is that nutrition
makes your drugs work better.
Nutrients will reduce the amount of work
the amount of damage control that the
the drugs have to do.
Follow me? So if you if you for example
use your occutive and this is another
strategy for Parkinson's. It's not
primary but you can still not octive
synaptive. I'm sorry. Synaptive. If you
use your synaptive and you're on
levodopa or carbodopa, you'll be able to
lower your dose on the dopamine if you
take your synaptive and if you start
using all the digestive support and if
you start using the metabolic support
and we don't want to look and it's kind
of our fault here because we're always
focusing on problem solution kind of
thing which is understandable if you
have a problem you want a solution but
really we want to look at overall
systemic health because when you have
overall systemic health you're not going
to have Parkinson's. Yeah, we can we can
target Parkinson's with all these things
we're talking about, but if we have
overall systemic health, you're not
going to have the Parkinson's and you
won't have to worry about other health
challenges. So, we want to look at
overall systemic health. And that's the
beauty of the Youngevity products.
There's no there's no Parkinson's
formula, but there's a healthy start
pack and there's a healthy brain and
heart pack. And there's, you know,
nutrients that are healthy blood sugar
pack. nutrients that support the nervous
system and support the cardiovascular
system and support the digestive system
as a system rather than just the
substantionigra, the area that's not
making the dopamine. The the doctor
strategy is let's go to the
substantigra. Not their fault. That's
how they're trained. So you don't want
to blame anybody, but it's not a
solution any more than thyroid hormone
is a solution for Hashimoto's.
>> Okay. So I have one um person who said
that they have a protein that's
accumulated
um inside their brain cells.
>> Amaloid.
>> Is it an amaloid?
>> Um they said that it's the alpha succin
we'll call it. It's a protect amaloid.
Amaloid is the criminal, the bad guy I
should say, and when it comes to
Alzheimer's, right? You've heard that,
I'm sure.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. But amaloid happens all over the
body. Alpha suclean is not amaloid, but
it's similar to amaloid. And it they say
it misfolds and forms these clogs.
That's the that's the theory. But my
opinion is it doesn't misfold.
They're like, "Oh, it's an oopsie." The
body doesn't make oopsies.
>> It's folding. It it changes its its
shape, misfolding they call it, as a
protective response to patch things up.
Why would it patch things up for damage?
To protect against damage. Everything's
secondary to damage. Everything is
secondary to degeneration. Degeneration
is damage. Everything is secondary to
something that's getting into the system
that's breaking it down or a combination
of nutritional deficiencies. And when
you have leaky gut and intestinal
problems, you have both because you got
to absorb nutrients to your intestine.
So, it's not hard. Let me say this
again. It's it's simple, but it's kind
of hard to change your life. And that's
really what we're talking about here is
to change our life. Most people have
Parkinson. Do little children have
Parkinson's?
>> Do you ever hear a teenager with
>> Not normally. Did
>> Did you ever hear of a a 20-year-old
Parkinson's? What does What does that
tell you when Parkinson's only happens
as you age?
What is that telling us?
>> It's degenerative. It's degeneration.
>> Yeah, it's it's right there. It's If
it's degenerative,
that means it's the accumulation of
things that are causing the body to
degenerate and in combination with the
with nutritional deficiencies. So,
anybody who has Parkinson's, number one,
all the food stuff. Number two,
metabolic syndrome. Number three, calm
the body down. Number four, pound
nutrients. Pound. When we talk about
pound, this is also important because
the the conventional wisdom is RDA,
right? Recommended daily allowance.
That's conventional wisdom.
>> Now, say what it really is.
>> The ridiculous deficiency allowance.
What we want to do is we want to
communicate
to the cells. It's all about the cells,
not the tissue, the cells, that life is
good. that there's plenty. When you have
a lot of money in the bank, you go on
vacation. You buy new clothes. You buy
things for your kids. You You feel
great. You spend money. You get a new
car. When you have a lot of money, when
you don't have a lot of money, you pull
back. You don't spend money. You eat
less food. You don't go on vacations.
You you take the bus instead of driving
for you save gas, whatever. That's how a
cell is. We want to tell the cell it has
lots of money. It can make lots of
collagen. It can make lots of hyaluronic
acid. It can make lots of immune immune
factors. It can do whatever it wants to
do. It has abundance.
Large concentrations of nutrients tell
the cell life is good. And that's the
reason why you want to pound the
nutrients with a few exceptions. zinc,
maybe selenium, you know, you don't want
to necessarily take too much of those,
but things like the B vitamins and
vitamin C and omega fats, you just want
to go crazy with them. Pound the body
with those nutrients. And then, of
course, if you have malabsorption at the
level of the gut, you got to fix that,
too.
>> Okay? So,
>> the B vitamins, by the way, the B
vitamins are especially important for
the nervous system, the brain and the
nervous system. The Bespecially thamin,
vitamin B1, and nasin, vitamin B3.
>> Okay? Okay. So, we're pounding the body
with nutrition.
>> Yes.
>> What about this thought that you're just
making expensive urine?
>> What about the thought that the moon is
made of green cheese?
>> If you told me the moon is made of green
cheese, what would I argue with you? I
wouldn't argue with you. I'd say fine.
Fine, Rebecca. It's made of green
cheese. Have a nice day. You know, so
people say that, I say, fine. Okay.
Expensive urine. Fine. You want your
urine expensive. You want everything
expensive. You deserve it. You should be
expensive urine. You should have
everything expensive. Your urine, your
saliva, everything. Everything. So, if
you pee some out, that's extra. Fine.
You got extra. At least it's a guarantee
you got extras. It's better to have
extra than than a shortage.
>> Not enough. That's for sure.
>> Absolutely. Um, now we have Bernardet
who's wanting to know what you can do
about ticks, which I think Bernardet's
referring to the bodily uncontrolled.
>> Wait, wait, wait. This ain't Friday.
This Monday night.
>> What do you mean?
>> You weren't coming on. I didn't know if
you were like,
you know, wanting me to fill in until
you got back or what, buddy?
>> Tick like nerv like ticks like movement
disorders.
>> Yes. B vitamins. B vitamins are your
nervous system vitamins. Omega fats,
magnesium,
selenium,
uh healthy brain and heart pack,
synaptive, and then look for other
symptoms. Nobody just has ticks. Nobody
just has movement disorders. So look for
other symptoms is always what you want
to do. Well, aside from digestive
issues, all other symptoms
have things beneath them.
Root, not fruit, right? So, if you have
leaky, if you have like Crohn's disease,
that's obviously an intestinal problem.
But if you have high blood pressure,
that may seem like it's a blood pressure
problem, but there's something
underneath it. The doctors can't really
treat high blood pressure effectively
except with antihypertensives
because the problem is not at the level
of the blood pressure. The problem is at
the level of the blood which is at in
turn at the level of the digestive
system and the blood sugar system.
So you if you have if you have anything
a symptom anything other than a
digestive symptom digestive symptoms are
foundational other than digestive
symptoms work backwards.
Go back the way you came.
So, I had a grandmother reach out to me
um early this morning. Uh share her
grandson since the age of six, he's now
nine, has had symptoms of Tourette's
with the involuntary movements,
involuntary
out verbal outbursts.
And
this all comes down to digestion.
It probably does, but but I would what I
would do when when Yes, probably because
it's always the triangle underneath, but
look for things. Yes, look for And it's
this is the very similar to autism. Same
idea. Look for things. You want to
become like a detective really. Really
what we're talking about here is
forensics like CSI. You know, the
Tourette's is the murder or the crime.
And now we want to look for clues. So,
we do forensics. We work backwards. What
are some of the clues? Really, it's
going to be digestive or it's going to
be blood sugar. Cortisol and thyroid are
usually involved, too, but they're not
the they're not the first things. The
first points in the triangle are the two
at the bottom. Triangle disease.
Triangle of disease. Triangle of
disease. Always.
>> All right. Thank you so much, AJ.
>> Hi, AJ.
>> All right. So, uh, farmers Ben. So uh
you you're talking about this triangle
and that everything goes uh everything
is related to the triangle.
>> Yes. Everything.
>> But you know
how do we how do we make it I mean like
for example Becca mentioned this this
young child dealing with these Tourett
syndrome.
>> Yes.
>> How do we how do we get her folks to
understand?
>> We don't we don't get her folks to
understand. You never get anybody
>> can't eat Fruity Pebbles and
>> you don't you don't you let people eat
Fruity Pebbles.
People get to eat Fruity Pebbles. They
get to do that. You don't tell people
what to eat. Have you ever tried telling
people what to eat when they're eating
French fries and you ever talk to them
about it? It doesn't go over well.
Nobody wants to be told. I don't ever
tell anybody what to eat. They have to
ask, you know. I don't even I don't tell
anybody anything unless they ask. Well,
clearly they asked Becca,
>> if they then you Oh, then then how do
you get them to see the relationship
you're saying between the food?
>> Yeah. I mean,
>> well, look,
>> food diary.
>> That's usually a good idea because then
they can see for themselves. Yeah.
People are completely oblivious to the
link. Yeah. Food diary. That's why I
like a food diary so much because you
can actually see the link for yourself.
Oh my god. Every time I have corn, I
bloat. Every time I have oats, I get
breakout. you know, every time I have
beans, I get hives, whatever. You you
start to see things. That's really the
that's the most important um reward
of a food diary is you get to see the
impact of what you're doing on your
body. Other than that, it's a mystery.
Oh my god, I'm breaking out. I have no
idea why. I I deal in skincare all the
time. Not Not as much in this country,
but I do business in Mexico. I got to
sneeze.
Excuse me.
Hang on a sec.
>> You gotta get you a tissue, Ben. Why
don't you take a tissue break?
>> No, I just it was there's nothing in
there. It's just there's some dust here
or something.
>> Anyway, um
so I I this this gal and she's been
working with me for a long time. She's
she's in the skincare business. Very
sweet, super smart lady. And so she
sends me a picture of this lady in
Mexico, this girl in Mexico, and she's
got the breakouts all in here. And I'm
telling you, when you break out all in
here and it's not like little individual
pimples like acne, it's rashy. It is a
100%
food condition or something ingested.
Almost always food. It could be some
kind of poison you'reing or drug or
something like that, but mostly food.
And yet this gal has been working with
me for years. She still sent me a
picture and said, "What do I do here?
The doctors are giving her retina and
antibiotics." You know, it's it's just
like it's kind of a mindset that we have
to we have to get this idea that the
body is on automatic. It's a closed
system like a circle and everything just
works perfectly inside the circle. It's
the law of physics that if you have a
closed system, everything's going to
stay the same. But because there's an
opening through food or through the
intestine or through the digestive
system, you got a problem. And this
opening
and the stuff that gets through the
opening is the most important parameter
that was going to determine health or
the lack thereof or longevity or early
demise.
There's nothing more important. Nothing.
And don't let anybody tell you. They
don't say it as much, but when I was in
pharmacy school, they used to laugh
about it. Oh, food. H chocolate doesn't
cause acne. Haha. Now they don't do it
as much. now because it's obvious
there's so many people that improve
improve their health when they change
the way they eat. And when you think
about it,
if you go to the grocery store, all the
food is foreign.
Even the produce is foreign. You got
stuff sprayed on the produce that didn't
exist 100 years ago. Even the chicken is
foreign because they're eating stuff
that they that has stuff on it that
didn't exist 100 years ago. It's a
completely different food supply. The
body has evolved on one diet and in the
last hundred years that diet is no
longer available
and what is available is a completely
corrupted food supply. So what what do
you think is going to happen, right?
>> Yes. From
>> and add add into the fact add into the
equation that we eat not because we're
hungry, we eat because we're under
duress or because things taste good. You
you got a recipe for disaster.
Pharmaceent in that article it mentions
that uh vitamin D which you mentioned to
me is more of a hormone. Yes. Vitamin D
folks who are deficient in vitamin D are
more susceptible
>> to everything.
And then Parkinson's
>> everything. Everything. Parkinson
vitamin D is for everything. For every
cell in the body needs vitamin D. Every
single cell, whether it's the thyroid or
whether it's the brain or whether it's
the kidneys or whether it's the bone or
the intestine, every single cell in
every organ is critically dependent on
vitamin D. Why? Because calcium
activates chemistry. And vitamin D
is the hormone that lets cal puts
calcium into the cells and into the
intestine into the blood from the
intestine. So vitamin D is for
everything. deficiency in vitamin D will
cause everything. It's not like it's not
a onetoone. Vitamin D is a master
vitamin. It's a hormone. It's not a
vitamin. It's a master substance, a
master nutrient.
>> Okay? So now,
>> and by the way, by the way, vitamin D
needs to be activated mostly by the
kidneys and the liver. Other cells too,
but other parts of the body too, but
mostly the kidney and liver. So if you
have kidney disease and liver disease,
you might not be activating your vitamin
D. So you may get vitamin D like through
your supplements or even the sun, not
it's not as much a problem as the sun
because your skin can activate vitamin
D, but but if you supplement with
vitamin D and you have kidney disease or
liver disease, you may not be activating
it effectively.
That's why they actually give you if you
have severe kidney disease, they'll give
you pre-activated
vitamin D, calcitriol.
It's a like a pre-activated form.
because you can't activate you're you're
going to be you're going to have a
problem with calcium.
>> Uh on Facebook, Pandue is saying and and
again Pandu is looking at the uh at the
fruit and not the root. She's saying
high or saying high dose 100 milligram a
day of aazanthin can reverse
Parkinson's.
>> That's silly. But it's good though.
That's not going to reverse Parkinson's.
But aazanthin is a pretty darn good
antioxidant. Aazanthin is um red. It's
what gives salmon their power to swim
upstream.
It's a incredibly incredibly valuable
nutrient. It's not going to cure
Parkinson's. That's not true. But it's
super valuable. Super super valuable.
And and it's not going to hurt if you
have Parkinson's. I love asanthin. I'm a
big fan.
And and your your your top three
antioxidants, vitamin C being number
one.
>> Yeah, but it doesn't quite work that way
because they all work together.
Probably alpha lipoic acid. I like that
one because that's both water soluble
and fat soluble. Um and then hydrogen.
Hydrogen is an incredible antioxidant.
Uh hydrogen, vitamin C, and um alpha
lipoic acid. The first three that come
to mind when I think of my favorites.
Uhhuh. And and Becca's asking what your
your
>> supplement. It's a supplement.
>> What's your favorite source to ask at
>> salmon? Pro? If I had to eat it from
food, I get salmon.
And by the way, salmon get it from
where?
>> How does salmon get their asses,
Anthony?
>> Uh,
>> wild caught. Always
>> wild caught.
>> Where they get? Where is No, she's
somebody saying wild caught. But where
where do uh where did salmon get their
asses? Anthra,
>> the most among probably the most
powerful food on the planet.
>> I would have to say seaweed of some
sort.
>> Algae. Yes. Algae. Exactly. Exactly.
Fucco brown algae has something in it
called fucazanthin
which is similar to asanthin. There's
probably asanthin in brown algae too.
Certainly red algae there's aanthin.
Uh there's
>> so there's so much you know the fact
that there's so much is good and it's
bad. It's bad because it's kind of
overwhelming and I've been studying this
stuff for 45 years and I still you know
I still learn you know five to 10
different new things every day and I've
been studying for 45 years. So you can
go it's endless how much you can study.
But it's good because you have so many
options.
There's so many things you could do.
There's so many ways that you can work
on degenerative disease.
you know just Parkinson's you can do uh
the night the nightly essence you can do
glucco gluccogel caps you could do
vitamin A and vitamin A you could do
collagen peptides you could do your I26
you could do your synaptic you could do
your healthy start pack you could do
your osteomag there's so many different
ways to approach these problems yes it's
overwhelming in a way I get that but the
good news is is that these are options
and that is the idea here in fact if I
was going to name longevity And like I
was going to give it another name. You
know what I call it?
>> Optionality.
>> Options.
>> I just call it options.
>> These are options.
>> Uh pharmacist Ben. Um
tons of stuff I could ask you, but
>> by the way, one of the latest treatments
for Parkinson's fecal transplants.
>> You didn't have to go. You know, you
could you could have left that one out.
I think it's interesting because that
just goes to show you how important the
microbiome is. Or you could take the
capsules, the oral feal capsules
>> is is uh shell shellish.
Shellish Irish moss. Okay.
>> Irish moss is great stuff. Yes. I don't
know if it's crack. I don't know what
it's touted to be, but yes, it's it's
seaweed.
>> Seaweed like grass. Grass and seaweed
are two of the most amazing nutritional
um complex compounds on the planet.
And it's no accident that the biggest
animals in the world eat seaweed and
grass.
>> Okay. So then what do you think of
pollen burst?
>> Pollen burst I'm not sure what you mean
by pollen burst. My friend Dino lives in
Hang on a second. Um he lives in New
York. He reminds me of you. Dino lives
right in the city. Yeah, my friend.
>> Be rough and tumble like me, huh? He is
rough and tumble. In fact, I'm gonna
introduce you guys, I think.
>> I'm gonna introduce you guys.
>> Cool.
>> Yeah, you remind you remind me of each
other. Um, yeah, he's a little older
than you, but I I've known him for a
long time. Um, so, uh, I forgot what you
just you're just saying to me.
>> Well, I said pollen burst because the
pollen the pollen grows.
>> Pollen. Yeah. P. Yeah, there's a little
of that stuff in there. What what is it
called in the polymer burst that that
gives it a name? They get they get the
name polymer burst from
polymer is more of an energy drink. I
forgot what the active ingredient is.
>> Sod
>> No, it's not SOD. There's something
else.
>> Um
>> SOD, by the way, is a very powerful
antioxidant
>> in the body. Super oxide dismutates.
>> U but but it's not much of a supplement.
But there's another there's another
ingredient in there that gives it the
pollen that gives it the name pol that
is the reason they call it polymer
burst. U but polymer burst is like you
know it's an energy drink or energy
powder.
>> Well if you if you ask a if you ask
Adrian it's got all I mean she put a
whole list together of all the all the
minerals and and that are in it
>> that's in the pollen.
>> That's in the pollen.
>> Yeah. The pollen pollen is very loaded
but there's not it's it's some kind it's
a special kind of pollen. I don't
remember what it is, but yeah, pollen is
is got a lot of good stuff in it for
sure. But you don't take pollen burst
for the pollen. You take it for the
buzz, for the energy, and it will give
you energy. I do it before I do George
Nory.
>> That's the only way I can stay up. She's
saying uh antibacterial
anti-prololiferative one two pollen
contains energizing proteins
as well as thank you for gene
sod
panthenic
uh
you you didn't nail it becca because all
of these things lipids vitamins minerals
green tea That's all in the pollen.
Lipids, vitamins, and minerals are all
in the pollen, not the green tea. But
>> e EC EGCG
>> EGCG is the act one of the active
components in green tea. Epigalicin
I can't I can't identify G40. Uh I can't
I can't identify.
>> Is this in the pollen? Is this in the
pollen molecule?
>> In the pollen burst?
>> No, but in the pollen molecule, not in
the pollen burst.
>> Uh not entirely sure. Um,
>> yeah. I don't I'm not sure. I Palmer is
not really a nutritional supplement as
much as it is an energy supplement. And
it is a good energy it's a darn good
energy supplement.
>> It's like a healthy version of coffee. I
mean, healthier coffee is somewhat
healthy, but a healthier version of
coffee.
Um,
and then I guess the last point that I
wanted to make uh for the night is
besides the fact that we really
appreciate all the time that you spend
with us and and um
>> thank you
>> questions you answer.
>> Um
uh there's one other question here. What
is pharmacist Ben Ben's view on urine
therapy? And you know Becca you've been
gone. We we actually talked about this.
>> Yeah, we did talk about urine therapy.
It's amazing. It's amazing. Urine
contains stem cells and peptides and
anti-aging compounds and steroid
hormones and immune anti-inflammatory
molecules. It's amazing stuff. The ura
is great for your skin, your hair. I
remember when I was a kid, I watched
this National Geographic special with
these these little kids, African kids,
washing their hair under a cow. cows
urinating on their hair and they were
washing their hair and I couldn't
understand why they were doing that but
later I real I found out ura which is in
urine is great for your skin and your
hair.
>> Okay, before we go Bruce is saying his
neighbor's son is considering a kidney
transplant. Dr. Wallick says diabetes
type one that you're born with it. Uh my
neighbor was diagnosed at four years old
and now he's taking the shots and he's
now in his 40s. At four years old, he
was diagnosed with diabetes type one.
Would that be considered a misdiagnosis?
>> I'm not quite understanding the
question. I don't know. Type one
diabetes.
>> Doc always says that you would you would
know you had type 1 diabetes before you
left the hospital because that would be
something that they would really
>> You mean when you're born a newborn?
>> Yeah. You you if you had type 1
diabetes, Dr. Wall would kind of would
say that you know before you left the
hospital.
>> What do you mean by you know as a
newborn?
>> As a newborn because that's something
that they would really key in on. I
>> I can't speak to Dr. Wallik. Dr. Wallik
probably knows more about nutrition than
has forgotten more about nutrition than
I know. So I'm not going to speak to Dr.
Wallik. But type 1 diabetes is an
autoimmune disease.
Okay? Autoimmune diseases are always
about dirty blood.
So, what I would be doing if I had type
1 diabetes is I'd be and it happens to
kids a lot. Milk is one of the is
thought to be a big problem with type 1
diabetes, but I would be looking for um
allergenic proteins and also digestive
problems. So, I'd be looking for milk
allergies, grain allergies, protein
allergies. Basically, all allergies are
proteins. And then I'd be doing a food
diary for all autoimmune diseases. Type
1 diabetes is rheumatoid arthritis of
the pancreas. Type 1 diabetes is um
shogrin syndrome of the pancreas. Type 1
diabetes is lupus of the pancreas. You
understand what I'm saying? It's the
same mechanism in a different place.
It's not special in any way in the realm
of autoimmune diseases. It's just
another generic autoimmune disease that
happens to be affecting the pancreas
versus the nerves and mo in multiple
sclerosis or the or the um the
connective tissue in lupus or shogun
syndrome or the rheumatoid arthritis or
just they're all the same. It's just a
different part of the body. The part of
the body doesn't matter. It only
matters, you know, the special part of
the body only matters to the specialist
because that's how he gets paid. It's
like if you have a, you know, if you had
a leg problem, you can go to the foot
doctor, you can go to the shin doctor,
you go to the knee doctor, you go to the
hip doctor, but it's all your leg.
You know what I'm saying? It's not like
your foot is different from your knee.
When it comes to degeneration when it
comes to whatever, you know, tweak you
made, the fact it's in your toe versus
your knee, it's not relevant. You know,
if you have an inflammatory condition in
one part of your body, it doesn't matter
that it's in that part of the body. It
matters that you have an inflammatory
condition. And that's kind of a mindset
that we have to look at. We got to get
away from the nomenclature, away from
the lo the locus of of where the the
degenerative condition occurs and back
to the basic mechanism which is
degeneration, inflammation, dirty blood,
leaky gut, metabolic syndrome. these
basic biological pathological
breakdowns.
>> Pharmacist Ben, we're going to end on
something very controversial for
Youngevity Nation.
>> Okay,
>> this topic is the most controversial
topic in Young Nation. I'm going to
bring Becca on for this. I would even
bring Keely on if she had her camera on.
This by far is the most controversial
topic in Young Jevity Nation. And the
question is pharmacist bed.
Can I use
olive oil that has been
packed in a nitrogenrich room or
>> can I use it? What do you mean? Can I
use it?
>> Okay. So, we say every time someone
calls and I say no oils of any kind
because this is our
>> no processed oils. We say no oils of any
kind because Dr. Wild says we don't play
Russian roulette. We don't know if that
oil is right.
>> We just say no oils of any kind.
>> He's right. If if you are going to do an
oil and there's some value to oils, it
has to be fresh. It has to be
refrigerated. It has to be in a dark
bottle. It has to be treated like
medicine. And even then, you want to
make sure that you're not letting it sit
around too long or not cooking with it
or exposing it to the air. So, you got
to be really careful with oils. Olive
oil, as far as oils go, is not there's
worse oils than olive oil. The ones that
are really problematic have lots of long
of omega6 fatty acids in longchain fatty
acids um with double bonds. Olive oil is
not one of the is more monounsaturated
than polyunsaturated. It doesn't have a
lot of double bonds. It's still it's
still not great. There is some medicinal
value to it. And in nutrition sometimes
we find that a food has value but it
also has problems. It's not cut and dry.
And so with with olive oil to the degree
it's I can't say yay or nay. I can't ask
you a question. Yay or nay. I can say to
the degree it's destabilized which you
don't know is the degree you're gonna
have a problem.
>> And I would never cook with it.
>> Never cook with it. Okay. So now what I
guess what I'm getting at is they're
saying online that and you know Dr.
Google, they're saying online and every
platform you go to on those reels,
they're saying that if you consume olive
oil, it will burn the fat in your cells.
>> No, I mean that that's just internet
stuff. I wouldn't I I'd want to see a
mechanism how it burns fat. It might rev
up the cell. It might speed up cell
cellular activity, but it's not going to
burn the fat in the cell. That's that's
a stretch.
and and any do would would coconut oil
be something that you would use?
>> Coconut oil is a completely different
entity. Coconut oil does not have the um
the longchain fatty acids. It has medium
chain fatty acids and short chain fatty
acids. The medium and short chain which
literally are short and medium in
length, those tend to be solid and more
stable.
The ones that are problematic are the
long ones. Think of like, think of like
a long chain of pearls versus a short
steel bar. The long chain is floppy.
It's going to it's more prone towards
damage when it's long. Short ones are
less prone towards damage, right?
>> Okay.
>> Because they're chunky. The the the uh
fats in butter and in coconut oil are
chunky.
So, they don't break down. They don't
flop around as much.
The long ones in corn oil, safflower,
peanut oil, etc., they flop around a
lot. And when they flop around, when
they're heated, they can fall. Things
can fall off and break. And then you get
oils that have broken and technically
they call them oxidized. And that's
where you run into the problem. The
short ones are much more much more
stable. So, they don't break down as
quickly. They don't break down hardly at
all. Actually, I you can keep coconut
oil uh for years before it breaks before
you have a problem with it. You know,
you could keep um butter out of the
refrigerator. You just keep it out, you
know, for I've never seen butter go bad.
Really? Have you?
>> No. I I I used to keep on the counter.
>> Yeah. It never goes bad because it's got
these chunky fats in it, short fats, as
opposed to the long long floppy ones.
>> So So then why are they saying this MCT
is good for the brain?
>> MCT is phenomenal for the brain because
it's in an incredible source of energy.
It's great for dieters. It's great for
the liver. It's great for people have a
gallbladder taken out. It allow MCTs can
be used without processing the way
ordinary fats can be used. When I was
working in um in a ped ICU, pediatrics
intensive care in Denver, they had a uh
they had a regional hub for kid little
kids who were born with digestive
problems from from crack moms from moms
who are on drugs. Well, moms are on
drugs, crack or heroin or whatever,
their babies are born with messed up
livers and gallbladders and intestines.
And uh D uh University of Colorado in
Denver was a regional hub for these
kinds of babies. And one of my jobs as a
pharmacist was to make medicine trays
for these babies. And they were all on
MCTs
because when you have a liver problem or
gallbladder issue um or even an
intestinal issue, your body has a
problem processing fats. MCTs are very
easy to process. They go right to work
and they're high energy.
>> So So would you consume the whole
coconut or you figure that the process?
>> Well, there's the co if you do the whole
coconut, you'll get some, but if you do
the coconut oil, you'll get a
concentrated amount of MCTs.
>> All right. Any any any commentary uh
Becca besides your you you want to know
about your his favorite snack? Is that
is that what
>> my favorite snack? Your favorite salty
or savory snack?
>> Salty or favorite? Salty or f? Um, nuts,
almonds. I like almonds and raisins.
>> Okay. When I was with pharmacist Ben,
the only thing that he would eat is
celery and carrots.
>> That's not the only thing I eat, but I
find celery and carrots to be very
filling, very handy. You can travel with
them. You can you don't have to cook.
They're perfect for a bachelor and
they're incredibly satisfying. They're
crunchy. They're super satisfying.
Carrots especially are incredibly
satisfying and they're cheap. A bag of
carrots is like a $150,
you know, for a bag of them and they'll
last you like two days and they're super
filling.
>> Okay. So, what's healthier? A raw carrot
or one that is steamed?
>> Uh,
they're they both have advantages. I
don't know which one would be healthier.
Raw. steamed releases the nutrients a
little bit. So, probably you get more
nutritional value out of steamed um to
the extent you steam it. Probably
steamed. U but you don't want to steam
it too much because you start to break
things down. So, you got to there's a
sweet spot. But I just grab a bag of
carrots out of the fridge or celery
sticks and it's just so easy. They're so
filling.
>> Okay, three quick questions on Rumble.
Um
uh how much MCT oil per day? What's the
diff difference between
>> real
>> MCT oil and MCT powder?
>> MCT powder is
compressed.
It's the same thing. It's just
compressed. I'm not sure how they make
it actually, but it's basically the same
thing. Uh and there's no real dose for
it. There's no there's no real there's
no way to know. You can't over
>> No, you can't really overdose. If you
really went crazy with it and drank a
whole bottle, you might get sick, like
nauseous, but you're not going to poison
yourself or anything.
>> Diminishing returns though
>> probably after a certain point.
>> I don't I you know, there's no real MCTs
aren't really like a like a um essential
nutrient. So, there's not a lot of
studies on MCTs and how they work. And
basically, they're easy to process. They
don't have to go through the entire fat
processing uh uh machinery that ordinary
fats do. So, they're great for people
who have problems with fat malabsorption
or or liver gallbladder issues or
pancreatic issues and or intestinal
issues and um they're very high energy.
Uh, pharmacist Ben, last week uh you
mentioned that we could benefit society
by having more people teaching others
like we try and do every day.
>> Yes.
>> And I have someone inquiring because of
your plea. Please, can we have another
plea?
>> Yes. You guys, you know, I love doing
this, but you can do it, too. And you
can make money doing it. You can help
people. You can be have the the
satisfaction of changing people's lives.
You can learn about nutrition for
yourself, for your family, for your
friends. And it's just a fascinating
thing to do. And and it's the Lord's
work helping people who are sick. This
is the greatest service job there is.
Why do you think I do this? And AJ,
Rebecca, for that matter, and Ruth Ellen
and Keely, and all the people who are
doing this, this is this is a great
service.
Don't I mean, come on, you guys. And
then you're going to make money at the
same time. And we'll help you and we
could be a family. We could do it all
together. Sign up with AJ at
fruitnotroot.com.
I'm sorry, rootnotfruit.com.
>> That's right. Rootfruit.com
and Pharmacist Ben, you are the absolute
man and we appreciate you. And like
Becca said, be a part of the solution.
Call 8559493377.
Pharmacist Ben. Thank you very much.
Yes. And we will see you Friday. you
will see me Friday and thank you so
much.
>> Thank you. You made it.
Hey.